This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。确定是人类。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将为您剖析在当今这个奇妙的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能以及复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在逆境之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字2%。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎收听《回溯往昔》（Look Back at it）播客。从1979年开始，对我来说那是具有重大意义的一年。1984年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英国人。在每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克兰蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年是一个疯狂的年份。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回溯往昔》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的学问》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套隐形的铠甲。它向世界传递出的信号是，你可不是好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不。意味着你就必须这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长的学问》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，这份特定的检测报告是你伪造了两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测报告。这需要一大批互联网侦探出动，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean is.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底被颠覆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终受到了惩罚。在iHeart无线电应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客节目中，我们探讨二十多岁时经历的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们的意义。
for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners. Wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today, I think I am possibly the most excited for this guest of all of our guests this season.
对我们的心理。大家好，欢迎回到本节目。欢迎再次收听本播客。新听友，老听友。无论你身处世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里收听又一期节目。今天，对于本赛季的所有嘉宾，我可能对这位嘉宾最为期待。
Because as you know, we love an evidence-based background. We love an informed guest. We love an actual scientific opinion in this space. and I think this person does all of those things. So we have Dr. David Rosmarin, who is an associate professor at Harvard Medical School and the founder of the Center for Anxiety, which provides, is it services to a thousand patients a year, I think. So he is incredible. He works a lot in obviously mental health and a lot around anxiety.
因为正如你所知，我们喜欢基于证据的背景。我们喜欢博学的嘉宾。我们喜欢在这个领域听到真正的科学见解。我认为这位嘉宾完美符合所有这些条件。所以我们请到了大卫·罗斯马林博士，他是哈佛医学院的副教授，也是焦虑症中心的创始人，我想该中心每年为一千名患者提供服务。所以他非常了不起。显然，他在心理健康领域做了大量工作，并且很大程度上围绕着焦虑症展开。
And he's also been featured in a number of amazing journals that we use on this podcast all the time. he's here today to talk about people's anxiety, their experience of anxiety, particularly in their 20s. So welcome. Thanks so much for having me on your show. It's a great honor and pleasure to be here. Yeah, I'm really, really excited, actually. I'm super pumped because I feel like maybe we should start firstly with letting you introduce yourself before I jump straight into my line of questioning, maybe talk about your journey to where you are now, why you took an interest in this particular area of research, this particular field as well? Sure. Well, I myself have definitely struggled with a good deal of anxiety over the years,
他还在许多我们这个播客经常引用的优秀期刊上发表过文章。他今天来到这里，是为了谈论人们的焦虑，他们的焦虑体验，特别是在二十多岁时的焦虑。所以，欢迎来到节目。非常感谢邀请我来参加你的节目。非常荣幸和高兴能来到这里。是的，其实我真的，真的很兴奋。我超级兴奋，因为我觉得也许我们应该首先让你自我介绍一下，然后我再直接抛出一连串的问题，也许你可以谈谈你是如何走到今天这一步的，为什么你会对这个特定的研究领域以及这个特定的专业产生兴趣？当然。嗯，多年来，我自己也确实经历过相当严重的焦虑，
and learning to deal with that, especially somebody who helps others and who does research in this topic and who now, you know, my clinics, like you mentioned, we're servicing over 1,000 people every year, has been so positive. It's been such a blessing for me to be able to have these challenging experiences. I'm not going to say that anxiety is fun. It is not. Nobody likes it. It's so uncomfortable. It's the kind of thing that we want to get rid of. But the times in my life when I've had that have made me so able to connect with my patients and in some ways more resilient. And I actually think today that anxiety can be a great catalyst for growth and for thriving if we use the right tools and approaches in order to get there.
学会应对这种焦虑，尤其是作为一名帮助他人、在这个课题上进行研究，并且现在，就像你提到的那样，我的诊所每年为超过1000人提供服务的人来说，这是一段非常积极的经历。能够有这些充满挑战的经历对我和来说是一种福分。我不会说焦虑很有趣。一点也不。没有人喜欢它。它是如此令人不适。这是我们想要摆脱的东西。但在我生命中经历焦虑的那些时期，让我能够更好地与患者产生共鸣，并在某种程度上变得更具韧性。事实上，我今天认为，如果我们使用正确的工具和方法去面对，焦虑可以成为成长和蓬勃发展的巨大催化剂。
Yeah, I love that. I think often people talk about these things without having a personal experience with them, which can be so frustrating, but I do think that that shared vulnerability, that shared experience is a bit of a unifier, a bit of a superpower. You know, I appreciate that. Now, let me ask you a question. Have you ever met anybody who didn't have anxiety before? It's so funny that you asked me this, because I think I've met a couple, and one of them is actually my partner. And he, I'm going to share all here. He's got a pretty stressful job.
是的，我非常喜欢这个观点。我认为人们在没有亲身经历的情况下谈论这些事情是很常见的，这可能会让人感到非常沮丧，但我确实认为这种共同的脆弱性、共同的经历是一种纽带，是一种超能力。你知道，我很感激这一点。现在，让我问你一个问题。你以前见过从不焦虑的人吗？你这么问真有意思，因为我想我确实遇到过几个，其中一个其实就是我的伴侣。而且他，我今天要在这里分享所有隐私。他有一份压力相当大的工作。
He's a solicitor. He's a lawyer. And I've never seen that man anxious. He'll be up until 2 a.m. Never. And I think it's the Ying and Yang, right? But in general, I know you are. You're expecting a different answer.
他是一名事务律师。他是一名律师。而我从来没见那个男人焦虑过。他甚至会通宵到凌晨两点。从来没有。我想这就是阴阳调和吧，对吧？但总的来说，我知道你。你可能期待一个不同的答案。
It's very few and far between the individuals who have never had anxiety before. And I think one of the biggest issues and one of the reasons anxiety gets out of control is that often we judge ourselves and we get very upset when we start to feel anxious, as opposed to realizing that this is a very human emotion. This is the kind of thing that's going to happen to the vast majority of people, except for your partner, and everyone, almost everyone at some point,
一生中从未有过焦虑的人寥寥无几。我认为最大的问题之一，也是焦虑失控的原因之一，在于我们常常会进行自我评判，当我们开始感到焦虑时会感到非常沮丧，而不是意识到这是一种非常人类的情感。这种情况会发生在绝大多数人身上，除了你的伙伴之外，每个人，几乎每个人在某个时刻，
is going to butt up against these feelings, these sensations, and they're uncomfortable when we want to get rid of it. But learning to grapple with it and to parlay that into positive ways in our life is really the name of the game as opposed to trying to squelch it and combat it. I think that really personally relates to me as well. The times I've been most anxious is when I've been asking myself to be least anxious, when I've really been suppressing that feeling because it wasn't comfortable. It wasn't necessary at the time.
都会与这些感觉、这些身体感受发生碰撞，当它们令人不适时，我们总是想要摆脱它们。但是学会与它搏斗，并将其转化为我们生活中的积极动力，才是真正需要做的事情，而不是试图去压制和抗击它。我认为这对我个人也深有感触。我最焦虑的时候，正是我要求自己不要焦虑的时候，当我真正去压抑那种感觉的时候，因为它让人不舒服。当时这并不是必需的。
I felt like it was interrupting other things in my life. But I do kind of want to just quickly start at the basics because I feel like when it comes to anxiety, there is somewhat a bit of misdive. information around there. Sometimes people, you know, I think people love to self-diagnose, people love to throw terms around. Like, I'm just so, you know, I've just got such bad anxiety, I've got such bad OCD, I've got such bad social anxiety, social phobia, whatever it may be. So can we just quickly strip back to the basics what exactly is not just anxiety, but some of the distinctions within the broader anxiety space, you know, perhaps between a panic disorder, social
我觉得它打扰了我生活中的其他事情。但我还是想从基础开始简单聊聊，因为我觉得说到焦虑时，周围似乎总是存在一些误导信息。有时人们，你知道，我认为人们喜欢自我诊断，人们喜欢到处抛出一些专业术语。比如，我只是太，你知道，我有严重的焦虑症，我有严重的强迫症，我有严重的社交焦虑，社交恐惧症，无论它可能是什么。所以我们能不能退一步，从基础讲起：究竟什么是焦虑？除了焦虑本身之外，在更广泛的焦虑领域内有哪些区别，比如恐慌症、社交焦虑、广泛性焦虑之间有什么不同？显然，并非每个人经历它的方式都完全相同。
anxiety, generalized anxiety, not everyone obviously experiences it the same way. Absolutely, yeah. If you strip it down, when you want to define anxiety, you really have to start with fear. Now fear is a healthy emotion that everybody, almost everyone, is programmed with, which involves adrenaline. adrenaline gets pumped into your bloodstream the minute you perceive a threat. And the fear response, otherwise known as the fight or flight response, is a healthy adaptation which helps you to survive. So you'll either flee or fight or freeze if you're in a certain situation and you're more likely to survive those situations. Babies, neonates who do not have a fight or flight response are usually, they usually don't survive. They usually will not
绝对的，是的。如果把它剥离到最基础的层面，当你想要定义焦虑时，你真的必须从恐惧开始。恐惧是一种健康的防御机制，几乎所有人都在出厂时就自带了这种程序，其中涉及肾上腺素。一旦你感知到威胁，肾上腺素就会立刻被泵入你的血液中。恐惧反应，也就是人们熟知的战斗或逃跑反应，是一种有助于你生存的健康适应机制。因此，在特定情况下，你会选择逃跑、战斗或僵住，这样你更有可能在这些情况下存活下来。婴儿，那些没有战斗或逃跑反应的新生儿通常，他们通常无法存活。他们通常活不过
survive beyond 30 days. It's a neurological, it's a neurological problem. In fact, if people don't have that. Now what's anxiety? Anxiety is the exact same thing. It shares the same brain circuitry. It shares the same neurobiology as fear. However, there's one key difference. It's a false alarm. So fear would be a real alarm like, oh no, I really have to get out of the way of this bus, which is careening towards me down to City Street. And anxiety would be, I'm in this social situation and I feel afraid. My fear response is going off, but it's unnecessary. Now I want to clarify. In other words, in other words, like I said, it's a false alarm. So I want to clarify, you are going to have false alarms. You're going to have them sometimes.
30天。这是一个神经学上的，这是一个神经学问题。事实上，如果人们没有那种机制的话。那么什么是焦虑？焦虑完全是一回事。它共享着相同的脑回路。它与恐惧共享相同的神经生物学基础。然而，有一个关键的区别。这是一个误报。所以恐惧会是一个真正的警报，比如，哦不，我真的得躲开这辆正朝城市街道狂奔而来的公共汽车。而焦虑则是，我身处这个社交场合，我感到害怕。我的恐惧反应正在触发，但这是不必要的。现在我想澄清一下。换句话说，换句话说，就像我说的，这是一个误报。所以我想澄清，你确实会经历误报。你有时会经历它们。
If, you know, sometimes in your kitchen or wherever it is, you're going to have, you know, your smoke alarm is going to go off. And that's good. That actually indicates that the batteries are working. The circuitry is working. And you have the protective factor in there, in place, the protective mechanism in place, that if there were a fire, it would wake you up. And it would save your life. That's much better than what's deadly with the smoke alarm is batteries, when the batteries die or when you don't have it. So anxiety just shows you that it's actually working, but it's a misfire of the fear system. Can I ask you a question?
如果，你知道，有时在你的厨房里或者无论在哪里，你会遇到，你知道，你的烟雾警报器会响起来。这其实是件好事。这实际上表明电池还在工作。电路正在工作。并且你体内有一个保护因素，已经到位，有一个保护机制已经就位，假使发生火灾，它会唤醒你。并且它会救你的命。这比烟雾警报器死机（电池耗尽或者没有电池时）要好得多，因为那种情况是致命的。所以焦虑只是向你表明它确实在运作，但它是恐惧系统的一次误击。我可以问你一个问题吗？
Because there's, which is kind of going back a little bit, but it's something that people ask me about all the time. It's obviously fight, flight and freeze response, parasympathetic and the automatic nervous system. No, parasympathetic and the sympathetic. What about the fawn response? Have you spoken, do you know much about this new edition? Well, the newest edition has really been freeze.
因为，这就有点回到之前的话题了，但这是人们经常问我的一个问题。显然有战斗、逃跑和僵住反应，副交感神经和自主神经系统。不对，是副交感神经和交感神经。那讨好（fawn）反应呢？你有聊过吗？你对这个新加入的分类了解多少？嗯，最新的版本其实一直是僵住。
You know, that has historically been ignored. In the last several years in the scientific literature, that's been brought up, especially in the context of sexual assault. There was recently some New York Times pieces about that and a couple of high-level scientific pieces about people freezing during sexual assault as being a part of the fear response. I don't know about form. Can you tell me about it?
你知道，这在历史上一直被忽视。在过去几年的科学文献中，这一点被提了出来，特别是在性侵犯的背景下。《纽约时报》最近发表了一些关于这方面的文章，还有几篇高水平的科学文章，讨论了人们在性侵犯过程中僵住作为恐惧反应的一部分。我对讨好反应不太了解。你能跟我讲讲吗？
Yeah. Well, it's interesting that you don't know about it, because now I'm thinking that perhaps I'm not getting it from the best sources. But the fawn response is basically mainly to do with, I think, social anxiety where you feel, obviously that false alarm that someone perhaps is going to reject you, someone doesn't like you, someone is going to do you harm in a social capacity. And instead of running away, instead of obviously fighting the person, both of which would be socially inappropriate, freezing might actually hurt your case more,
是的。嗯，真有趣你对它不了解，因为现在我在想，也许我并没有从最好的渠道获取信息。但讨好反应基本上主要与，我认为是社交焦虑有关，在那里你会感受到，显然那种虚假的警报，即某人可能会拒绝你，某人不喜欢你，某人在社交层面上会伤害你。而你没有逃跑，也没有去跟对方打架（这两者在社交场合显然都不合适），僵住其实可能会让你的处境更糟，
you fawned so you overly compliment them you kind of make yourself seem quite subservient and like they are in control so it's interesting that perhaps this isn't coming up as much in your space because maybe it's um i don't know the freeze response i understand the fawn one is one that i think i don't understand as well because it doesn't seem as natural to me as part of a fear response it feels more like an intentional behavior rather than an automatic behavior. I'll tell you what I think is really going on there. In some ways, the person, you know, fight, the fight response is when you're doing something in order to ward off anxiety. The flight response is when you're running away and you're escaping. So it actually in some ways is under the category of the fight response. I understand it's not fighting because you're not fighting against the person, but really it's in the category of are you doing something positive in order to tamp down your anxiety and to deal with it? Or are you doing, are you withdrawing from a situation? which would either be in the form of freezing in its extreme force, form, or in the form of fleeing or withdrawal. So form is a socially appropriate way of trying to engage people.
于是你选择了讨好——你过度恭维他们，你把自己表现得相当卑微，表现得好像是他们在掌控一切。所以很有意思的是，为什么这个概念在你的领域里没有被过多提及？也许是因为它，我不知道。僵住反应我是理解的，但讨好反应是我觉得我不太理解的一个，因为它在我看来作为恐惧反应的一部分并不是那么自然，它感觉更像是一种有意为之的行为，而不是一种自动反应。我来告诉你我认为那里真正发生了什么。在某种程度上，一个人，你知道，战斗反应是当你为了抵御焦虑而做某事时。逃跑反应是当你逃跑并躲避时。所以在某种程度上它其实属于战斗反应的范畴。我明白这并不是真正的打架，因为你不是在和对方打架，但它确实属于以下范畴：你是在采取积极的行动来压制焦虑并处理它吗？还是说，你在从情境中退缩？
And, yeah, that could definitely be mediated. Social anxiety is one context, one way in which anxiety manifests, perhaps particularly for young people, I'll even matter. I think that is the case. I think generalized anxiety disorder and social anxiety, social anxiety, something I get questions about all the time. But something else I want to speak about because one thing you talk about is how, and you spoke about this in your Washington Post-Washington Journal article,
这要么表现为极端形式的僵住，或者表现为逃跑或退缩。所以讨好是一种试图与人建立联系的社交合适的方式。
Wall Street Journal article, yeah. And it was super fascinating. It's how perhaps our experience of anxiety has changed in recent decades, but also the approach to diagnosing anxiety has also changed. You know, previously, obviously, in decades long gone, we really only had, like, kind of the broader term of, like, neuroses, and people would experience, you know, a great deal of stigma and discrimination. There wasn't really a system for dealing with this pattern of symptoms, this pattern of behaviours, this pattern of tendencies. Nowadays, we have that sideway so much more accepting. We're so much more aware of what this is.
而且，是的，这绝对是可以调节的。社交焦虑是焦虑表现的一种背景、一种方式，也许对年轻人来说尤其如此，甚至对其他人也是如此。我认为确实如此。我认为广泛性焦虑障碍和社交焦虑，社交焦虑是我一直被问到问题的话题。但我想谈谈的另一件事是，你谈到了某种情况，而且你在你的《华盛顿邮报》-《华盛顿杂志》文章中也谈到了这一点，
But what has that changed? Has it had any consequences now that perhaps the bar has been lowered, the threshold is lower? I believe there have been some unintended consequences of our greater literacy of mental health. And I think on the one hand, it's been a great thing. Like, as you say, you know, we have more technologies today. We have more solutions. On the other hand, there is an insidious message that your generation has that had I grown up with this, I would have had crippling anxiety.
《华尔街日报》的文章，是的。那真的非常吸引人。它讲述了我们对焦虑的体验在近几十年来是如何发生变化的，同时诊断焦虑的方法也发生了变化。你知道，在此之前，显然在过去的几十年里，我们真的只有诸如神经症之类更广泛的术语，人们会经历大量的污名化和歧视。当时并没有真正建立一套系统来处理这种症状模式、行为模式和倾向模式。如今，我们有了这种系统，社会要包容得多。我们对这到底是什么有了更多的认识。
And that message is that you need to feel good all the time. You need to look good all the time. You need to be high achieving. You need to be hidden to the nines. You know, everything's got to be perfect. And that is just not going to happen. It's, if you're expecting perfect equanimity and perfect happiness, you know, you're going to be disappointed. And then the minute you start to feel anxious, then you're judging yourself. You're nervous that something's wrong. You're comparing yourself to everybody else. And then you're just going down the tubes. literally releases more adrenaline when you perceive anxiety as a threat, which by from a biophysical standpoint increases your anxiety. I think this is the core of the anxiety epidemic today is that we have bought in and sold. We have sold this message, especially to younger generations that you need to feel good all the time. It's a lie. It's just not going to happen. And the more we can accept that distress is part of life, the better we're the more resilient we can be, and the better position we are to be able to handle a normal adversity.
但是这种改变带来了什么？现在门槛降低了，标准放宽了，这是否带来了一些后果？我认为我们对心理健康的认知度提高，也带来了一些意料之外的后果。一方面，这绝对是一件好事。正如你所说，你知道，我们今天拥有更多的技术。我们拥有更多的解决方案。另一方面，你的这一代人接受到一个潜移默化的信息，如果我和你们一起长大，我也会患上严重的焦虑症。
So I completely agree with that. I think that the pressure to be exceptional is significant, is something that every single person in this generation would tell you about. So do you think that it is specifically cultural or social, or are there other factors, the one that I always think of, And perhaps it does play into an environmental causes, the rise of social media and certain technologies, which have made it so much easier to compare yourself to others,
而这个信息就是：你必须无时无刻都感觉良好。你必须无时无刻都看起来光鲜亮丽。你必须是个成就卓越的人。你必须无可挑剔。你知道，一切都必须完美。而这根本是不可能的。如果你期待的是完美的平静和持续的幸福，你知道，你注定会失望。然后，当你开始感到焦虑的那一刻，你就会开始自我审判。你就会紧张，觉得有什么地方不对劲。你会拿自己和所有人作比较。然后你就会一落千丈。当你把焦虑视为一种威胁时，它实际上会释放出更多的肾上腺素，从生物物理学的角度来看，这会加剧你的焦虑。我认为这就是当今焦虑流行病的核心所在——我们已经接受并买账了。我们把这个信息兜售了出去，特别是向年轻一代兜售，告诉他们你需要时刻感觉良好。这是一个谎言。这根本不会发生。我们越是能接受痛苦是生活的一部分，我们就能变得越有韧性，也就处于更好的位置去应付正常的逆境。
so much easier to see everything that's absolutely terrible in the world. Do you think that has a role as well? It does. It definitely does. I think it worsens trends within countries. But if you look between countries, it's different. Like levels of anxiety in Europe are substantially better than they are in the United States. States. And in Middle Eastern countries, it's even better. And even in India, where it's very common for people to use social media, people's anxiety is not quite as bad. And the reason why is because
对此我完全赞同。我认为追求卓越的压力是巨大的，这是这一代人中的每一个人都会向你提及的事情。所以你认为这是具体的文化或社会的产物，还是有其他因素？我总是会想到的一个因素，也许它确实与环境原因有关，那就是社交媒体和某些科技的崛起，这使得与他人进行比较变得如此容易，
in many cultures, I don't know about Australia. Unfortunately, I don't know very much about it, but I know in the United States, social media is used to replace in-person social engagement. That's usually not, in Mediterranean countries, it's not usually like that. In the Far East, it's as much. There's still social engagements which occur and those are complicated. You have to get on a subway, you have to deal with someone who I don't know they have bad breath. You have to you know see somebody at that party who you don't like. You have to, you know, it's more, you can't just shut off the conversation and if you don't look good, you're still there. Like if someone spills coffee on you, like you're you're at the party. Like you're,
看到世界上所有绝对糟糕的事情也变得如此容易。你认为这也起到了作用吗？确实有。绝对有。我认为它加剧了各国国内的趋势。但如果你在不同国家之间进行比较，情况就不同了。比如欧洲的焦虑水平明显比美国好。而在中东国家，情况甚至更好。甚至在印度，尽管人们非常普遍地使用社交媒体，但人们的焦虑也没有那么严重。原因在于
you're, you're, we have to deal with those, you're there. You can't just shut it off or like, you know, go to your cupboard and then change and then come back on with a pixelated image. So all of those are great for building resilience and something that, at least in the United States, we are not doing very well. That's really interesting because I think that it's massive in Australia. I literally just finished a project for Medibank called We Are Lonely. And it talks about how social media has reduced that sense of connection. But the other thing that I find, this is like a personal rant,
在许多文化中——我不了解澳大利亚。不幸的是，我对澳大利亚了解不多，但我知道在美国，社交媒体被用来替代面对面的社交互动。通常情况并非如此，在地中海国家，通常不是这样的。在远东地区，也没有那么严重。仍然会有社交互动发生，而这些互动是很复杂的。你必须挤地铁，你必须应付一个我不知道是不是有口臭的人。你必须，你知道，在那个派对上见到某个你讨厌的人。你必须，你知道，这更像，你无法直接关闭对话，如果你看起来不够光鲜，你还是得待在那里。就像如果有人把咖啡洒在你身上，你还是得留在派对上。就像你在，
that I have all the time is our society is kind of moving towards a place where we don't have community anymore. You know, previously we used to a lot of, you know, groups were quite religious. You know, you used to go to Sunday church or, you know, used to be able to pop over to your friend's house. And now that's kind of replaced with being able to have those interactions online. And so I really kind of agree with what you're saying in the sense that you no longer get that exposure to perhaps the everyday stresses that you can engage with and mediate? Is that kind of a hundred percent. Relationships are messy.
你在，你在，我们必须去应对这些，你就身在其中。你不能直接关掉对话，或者，你知道，走到你的储藏室里换身衣服，然后带着像素化的图像重新上线。所以所有这些对于培养韧性都是极好的，而这一点，至少在美国，我们做得并不是很好。这真的很有趣，因为我认为这在澳大利亚非常普遍。我刚刚为Medibank完成了一个名为《我们很孤独》（We Are Lonely）的项目。它讨论了社交媒体如何减少了那种连接感。但我发现的另一件事——这是一个我经常有的个人吐槽，
You know, they're all messy. And the people who you love the most and you feel connected with the most and the people who you're going to feel the most elated with and the most excited with are also probably the people who are going to drive you the most insane. That's usually the way it goes. Yeah, I think people need that reminder coming up to Christmas, honestly. That's incredibly contextually relevant. Of course, like if we're talking about trauma and if we're talking about, you know,
我们社会正在走向一个不再有社区的地方。你知道，以前我们经常有很多宗教性质的团体。你知道，你过去常常去参加周日教堂，或者，你知道，你可以顺便去朋友家串门。而现在，这种方式在某种程度上被能够在线上进行这些互动所取代了。所以我真的很赞同你的观点，即你不再接触到那些你可以参与并加以调解的日常压力？这算是一种吗？百分之百。人际关系是纷繁复杂的。
actually dangerous situations and, you know, people who are sociopaths, like I have no tolerance for that. And, you know, I'm not saying that we should subject ourselves to actual danger. But, you know, the people who I know who are most connected with others also put up with a lot of garbage. And I see that as a strength. I see that as a strength and one that we don't really talk about very much. I also think it's this interesting thing where it's like you can still interact with those people with boundaries like you know not completely withdraw I think this is a completely different topic we're getting on to I'm just trying to pick your brain for all that it's work but I want to well it's related to anxiety
你知道，它们都很杂乱。那些你最爱的人、你感觉连接最深的人，以及那些带给你最多狂喜和兴奋的人，可能也是最让你发疯的人。事情通常就是这样。是的，老实说，我觉得大家在临近圣诞节时确实需要这个提醒。这具有极高的语境相关性。当然，如果我们谈论的是创伤，如果我们谈论的是，你知道，真正危险的情况，以及，你知道，反社会人格者，那我对此是零容忍的。并且，你知道，我并不是说我们应该让自己置身于真正的危险之中。但是，你知道，我认识的那些与他人联系最紧密的人，同时也包容了大量的破事。我认为这是一种力量。我认为这是一种力量，也是一种我们并不经常讨论的力量。我也觉得这是一个很有趣的现象，就像你仍然可以在有界限的情况下与那些人互动，比如你知道不要完全退缩。我想这是一个完全不同的话题，我们正在深入探讨。我只是想从你这里汲取所有的智慧，但我希望——这与焦虑有关，
because when we are dealing with people you know those people who need those boundaries there's that sense of inside of us like should I put up a boundary do I just walk away do I tell them off like and that creates a lot of anxiety Do we actually face that anxiety and deal with the issue? Or do we just walk away? And I think in our culture, when we are trying to cultivate our emotional experience on a minute-by-minute basis, the minute I start to feel anxious, I'm like, I'm not dealing with this. I don't think that's healthy.
因为当我们与人交往时，你知道，那些需要设定界限的人，我们内心会有一种感觉：我是该设立一个界限？还是直接走开？我是该训斥他们一顿？——这会产生大量的焦虑。我们是真的去面对这种焦虑并解决问题？还是直接走开？而且我认为在我们的文化中，当我们试图按分钟来管理我们的情感体验时，只要我开始感到焦虑，我就会想：我才不处理这破事呢。我认为这并不健康。
I don't think that's the way we're meant to be. Learning to have boundaries and to enforce those boundaries continuously is a great, great skill. It's not easy, but it's an important. skill that I don't think we practice enough. I think it's also this trend of conflict aversion as well, like wanting to avoid all kinds of conflict. I've seen that in my own life. Perhaps that people pleasing tendency as well, which I think our generation has a lot more of, not to offend. I think there is a lot more people pleasing in for people, for folks in their 20s than there was when I was 20.
我不认为这是我们原本应该有的状态。学会设定界限并不断地执行这些界限，是一项非常了不起的技能。这并不容易，但这是一项重要的技能，而我认为我们练习得还不够。我也认为这也是一种逃避冲突的趋势，就像想要避开各种各样的冲突。我在自己的生活中也看到过这一点。也许也存在那种讨好型人格的倾向，我认为我们这一代人这种倾向要多得多，为了不冒犯别人。我认为现在的20多岁的年轻人，身上的讨好型人格要比我20岁时多得多。
Yeah, absolutely. But I want to ask you this question because this is the thing I think kind of the main part of the sandwich here that I'm super fascinated by, which is how do you think that our approach to treating anxiety has changed? And I'm going to say my fascination with this, you know, with this philosophy that you have with perhaps your opinion on this, is quite selfish of me. It comes from a personal place. It's, you know, the over-medicalization of anxiety.
是的，绝对的。但我想问你这个问题，因为这是我认为这里最核心的部分，我对此感到非常着迷，那就是：你认为我们治疗焦虑的方法发生了怎样的变化？我要说明我对这个问题的迷恋，你知道，对于你的这种哲学，对于你对此的观点，这可以说是出于我个人的私心。它来自我个人的经历。那就是，焦虑的过度医疗化。
I was diagnosed with anxiety when I was quite young. It's been a constant in my life, as it sounds like it has been in yours. And when I was on 19, I went on Lexa Pro, which is kind of a dual anxiety, depression medication, was also like very quickly prescribed Valium, which I no longer use. And so I guess by way of my actions, I've kind of benefited from this more medical, biomedical approach. But you say that we can do things differently. And obviously, this is not me asking you for personal medical advice. that would be entirely inappropriate. But more in the sense of like, what does that mean?
我年纪很小时就被诊断出患有焦虑症。它一直是我生活中的常态，听起来在你的生活中也是如此。当我19岁的时候，我开始服用来士普（Lexapro），这是一种双效焦虑、抑郁药物，同时也很容易就被开出了安定（Valium），不过我后来不再使用它了。所以我想通过我的种种行为，我其实从这种更偏向医学、生物医学的方法中受益了。但你却说我们可以用不同的方式来处理。显然，我这不是在向你征求个人的医疗建议，那将是非常不恰当的。而是从更广泛的意义上讲：这意味着什么？
What is this different approach? How could we do this differently without perhaps taking a pill that sometimes people think is going to be this miracle, this one thing that is going to change their life? Great questions. First and foremost, I'm not against pharmacology in any way. And I do see, I would say more than 50% of my patients use pharmacology, use medicine, psychiatric medications. and I'm a supporter of that as long as it's taken with certain intent. Now, I don't know what you were told when you were 19 and put on Lexapro, but the fact that you were put on Lexapro first and Valium 2nd indicates that probably it was something along the lines of,
这种不同的方法是什么？我们怎么能用不同的方式来做到这一点，而不是去吃一颗有时人们以为会是奇迹、能改变他们一生的药丸呢？问得好。首先也是最重要的，我绝不反对药物治疗。而且我确实看到，可以说超过50%的患者都在使用药物治疗、使用精神科药物。只要这些药物是在特定的意图下服用的，我对此表示支持。现在，我不知道你19岁开始服用Lexapro时别人是怎么跟你说的，但你先是被开了Lexapro，后来又被开了安定，这表明情况可能类似于，
I'm going to take this in order to reduce my anxiety so I can manage day-to-day and be able to overcome it. If your intent was I would need to get rid of these feelings and I cannot have them ever again, Firstly, that doesn't work. There's no medication that will take away your anxiety, because if it could, it would take away your fear response, which would actually be maladaptive. That would not be healthy for you at a neural level, at an emotional level, behaviorally or in any other way. We need people's fear systems to be in place so that you can be protected if you need it.
我吃这个是为了减轻焦虑，这样我就能应付日常生活并克服它。如果你的意图是“我需要摆脱这些感觉，而且我绝不能再有这种感觉了”，首先，这是行不通的。没有任何一种药物能彻底消除你的焦虑，因为如果能的话，它就会消除你的恐惧反应，这实际上会产生适应不良。无论是在神经层面、情感层面、行为层面还是其他任何方面，这对你来说都是不健康的。我们需要人类的恐惧系统保持在位，这样当需要时你才能得到保护。
So we're not going to strip that down. There would be catastrophic consequences if that were the case. But what can be done is to tamp it down a little bit so that a person has enough to anxiety that they can tolerate. Sometimes people's anxiety gets so high that they just cannot tolerate it. They can't use it to thrive in a positive way in their lives. So we need to to pharmacologically reduce it to a regular level. Now benzodiazepines, Valium, Ativan, Valium, Clonopin, and the like are completely different. They work on a different brain system called GABA. And what those do is they sort of immediately reduce your anxiety, Xanax.
所以我们不会把这个系统拆掉。如果真是那样的话，将会带来灾难性的后果。但可以做到的是稍微压制它一下，让一个人拥有他们能够承受的适度焦虑。有时人们的焦虑会飙升到他们根本无法承受的地步。他们无法利用它在生活中积极地蓬勃发展。所以我们需要通过药物将其降低到一个常规水平。现在，苯二氮卓类药物，如安定、阿提万、安定（Valium）、氯硝西泮（Clonopin）之类的是完全不同的。它们作用于一个叫做GABA（γ-氨基丁酸）的不同脑系统。这些药物的作用是它们能迅速减轻你的焦虑，比如阿普唑仑（Xanax）
is your classic one, right? They immediately reduce your anxiety. Now, often people are given those as a first-line treatment, and I do not think that's in general. In general, I don't think that's a wise practice. I don't think that's a wise medical practice. Because what ends up happening is people assume, the minute I feel anxious, they're taking this fast-acting medication.
就是最典型的一种，对吧？它们会立即减轻你的焦虑。现在，人们经常被开具这些药物作为一线治疗，而我认为这总体上并非明智的做法。总体而言，我认为这不是明智的医疗实践。因为最终发生的情况是，人们以为，只要我感到焦虑，他们就会服用这种起效快的药物。
Lexa Pro is slower acting over time. So it'll reduce your anxiety over a period of four to six weeks to a reasonable level, and then you can reduce it over time if you want. You can reduce your dose and then tolerate higher levels. With benzos, it's a different game. And that approach is really in some ways reinforcing the idea, I shouldn't feel anxious,
Lexapro起效较慢，需要随时间推移逐渐发挥作用。因此它会在四周到六周的时间内将你的焦虑降低到一个合理的水平，然后如果你愿意的话，你可以随着时间推移逐渐减量。你可以减少剂量，然后去承受更高的焦虑水平。对于苯二氮卓类药物，情况则完全不同。这种方法在某种程度上实际上强化了这样一种观念：我不应该感到焦虑，
I don't want to ever feel anxious, I have to get rid of this anxiety or something catastrophic will happen. And all of those messages just sensitize us further often, and I've seen this in hundreds of cases, where people were told by a pharmacologist, you need to take this Xanax or whatever it is in order to cope with their anxiety, it will take it away. And it doesn't. And then they feel even worse about themselves the next time their anxiety goes higher.
我永远不想感到焦虑，我必须摆脱这种焦虑，否则就会发生灾难性的事情。所有这些信息往往只会进一步让我们变得更加敏感，我在数百个病例中都看到过这一点：精神科医生告诉患者，你需要服用阿普唑仑或无论什么药来应对焦虑，它会把焦虑赶走。然而事实并非如此。结果下次当他们的焦虑再次升高时，他们对自己的感觉反而更糟糕了。
And they end up on three, four, five medications. Then, you know, it can get very complicated very quickly. I find that very personally relevant that made a lot of sense to me. I think it's also something I realized, I used to have a really terrible fear of flying, terrible claustrophobia and that's why I used Valium. And you know what? The fear response was not there, but the level of avoidance that I had towards the activity increased like crazy because I became more fearful of that fear response, right?
最后他们不得不服用三、四、五种药物。然后，你知道，情况会迅速变得非常复杂。我发现这与我个人息息相关，这对我来说很有道理。这也是我意识到的一点，我曾经对坐飞机有着非常可怕的恐惧，有可怕的幽闭恐惧症，这也是我当时使用安定（Valium）的原因。你知道吗？恐惧反应虽然不在了，但我对这种活动的逃避程度却疯狂地增加了，因为我变得更加害怕那种恐惧反应了，对吧？
Because I was teaching myself that it was so dangerous, that it was so scary that I was so unable to cope that I needed to be taking this medication at high doses. What did you think would happen? What did you think would happen if you just let your anxiety go? Oh, I had some crazy irrational fears. That's the other part about, you know, I think anxiety. It's quite irrational, right? And it was, you know, if I was on this plane and I wasn't taking Valium,
因为我在教导自己这是如此危险，如此可怕，以至于我完全无力应对，我必须大剂量地服用这种药物。你当时觉得会发生什么？如果你只是任由焦虑顺其自然，你觉得会发生什么？哦，我有一些疯狂的非理性恐惧。这就是关于，你知道，我认为焦虑的另一个部分。它相当不理性，对吧？当时觉得，如果我在飞机上而没有服用安定，
I was going to have a panic attack and I was going to try and rip open the doors of the plane. Because I was so scared. I was like, is this a possibility? Could I completely, could I seriously hurt other passengers on board? or I think worrying about embarrassing myself. And then I think I examined the fear further. And I was like, and the thing I always say for people to do is the so what. So you have a panic attack on the plane, so what?
我会恐慌发作，我会试图去扯开飞机的舱门。因为我太害怕了。我当时想：这有可能吗？我真的会严重伤害机上的其他乘客吗？或者我觉得是在担心让自己出丑。然后我想我进一步审视了这种恐惧。我总是对人们说的一句话是：那又怎样。所以你在飞机上恐慌发作了，那又怎样？
So I'm going to embarrass myself, so what? I think the thing that I realized in that, and you say this, and you said it before, and I love, love this phrase, you have to get comfortable with being uncomfortable. How do you think we get there? Because being uncomfortable is not something that we particularly enjoy doing. Nobody likes it, but it's going to happen sometimes, and we do have to get used to it. Now, the question is how much discomfort? Can we, when we, listen, I feel anxious throughout, I wouldn't say on a weekly basis, certainly a couple times a month.
所以我让自己出丑了，那又怎样？我从这件事中意识到的一点是——你也是这么说的，你之前说过，我非常非常喜欢这句话：你必须学会适应不适感。你认为我们是如何做到这一点的？因为感到不适并不是我们特别喜欢做的事情。没有人喜欢它，但它有时确实会发生，我们确实需要习惯它。现在的问题是：要承受多少不适？当我们，听听，我整个过程中都会感到焦虑，我不会说每周都焦虑，但一个月肯定有好几次。
Something comes up that makes me feel viscerally uncomfortable, and when my stress level is high, I'm more likely to have that. I'll tell you what I do. I'll be very autobiographical here. I lean right into it. I'm feeling terrible right now. What am I upset about? And I bring it on. I think right towards it.
总会有一些事情发生，让我感到由衷的不适，当我的压力水平很高时，我就更可能经历这种感觉。我来告诉你我是怎么做的。我在这里非常自传式地剖析一下。我直接迎难而上。我现在感觉糟透了。我在烦恼什么？我把这种感觉引出来。我直接朝着它想。
And if I'm feeling, if something makes me feel more uncomfortable, I will gravitate even more towards it. I'll talk about it in great detail with people, get it off my chest, embrace it, let the fear wash over me. It is, it's sort of like ripping off a band-aid. Yeah. Right? Just like, we're going to do this. It's really hard. And it hurts.
如果我感到，如果有什么事情让我感到更加不适，我会更加向它靠拢。我会和别人详细谈论它，把它从我胸口倾吐出来，拥抱它，让恐惧席卷我。这就有点像撕掉创可贴。是的。对吧？就像：我们要这么做。这真的很难。而且很痛。
It really hurts. It's bad. But it, I'll tell you what ends up happening when you lean into it is what we talked about before, the parasympathetic. of the system, you have wiring and you have chemicals inside of you, which will calm you down. We see over 1,000 patients a year in my practice. How many of them have had a panic attack that lasted more than 90 minutes ever? I'm sure it's zero. Zero.
真的很痛。感觉很糟。但是，我来告诉你当你迎难而上时最终会发生什么——就像我们之前谈到的那样，副交感神经。神经系统，你体内有着相应的神经布线和化学物质，它们会让你平静下来。在我的诊所里，我们每年接待1,000多名患者。其中有多少人曾经历过持续时间超过90分钟的恐慌发作？我敢说这个数字是零。零。
The number is zero. And my colleagues who have similarly sized clinics treating tens of thousands of patients on an annual basis for decades, I have spoken with them. and the number of patients who have had a panic attack more than 90 minutes ever I'm going to go for the same answer to I'm going to say zero how are the number of people who have crashed their car during a panic attack it doesn't happen the number of people who've gotten up in the middle of a plane and started running around and stabbing people with the plastic fork listen I'm going to say maybe at least one I've seen some weird
数字就是零。我的同事们也有规模相当的诊所，几十年来每年治疗成千上万名患者，我和他们交流过。经历过超过90分钟恐慌发作的患者人数——我还是会选同样的答案，我会说是零。有多少人在恐慌发作期间把车给撞了？这根本没有发生过。有多少人从飞机中间站起来，开始四处乱跑，用塑料叉子捅人？听着，我会说至少有一个吧？我看过一些奇怪的
car in videos but it probably is zero well there was that one time no I'm kidding the answer is zero people don't do that when you're in anxious, you're actually more in control of yourself. You're dealing with your own emotions. You're not, and often you can't even tell. Like people say, everyone can see I'm anxious. No, they're looking at themselves. They're not looking at you. What is it called the spotlight effect? Everything that we do seems to be like super, super obvious to other people, but we're all in our kind of own internal lives and internal minds. That's really interesting because I think that that's a really important reminder to people who experience kind of the shame cycle of like, this is super,
车祸视频，但可能真的是零。好吧，有那么一次——不，开玩笑的，答案是零。人们在焦虑的时候不会那样做。当你焦虑时，其实你对自己的掌控力更强。你在处理自己的情绪。你并没有——而且通常你甚至都看不出来。就像人们说的那样：“每个人都能看出我很焦虑。”不，他们都在关注他们自己。他们根本没看你。这叫什么效应？聚光灯效应？我们所做的一切在别人看来似乎都超级、超级明显，但其实我们都活在各自的内心生活和内心世界里。这真的很有趣，因为我认为这对那些经历“羞耻循环”的人来说是一个非常重要的提醒：这超级、
embarrassing. The one thing I do and I is really similar to you is like I tell myself I'm excited by the feeling because I think anxiety and excitement feel very, very similar. So I'm like, this is the most exciting feeling ever. It's actually the same chemical. It's adrenaline. You know, adrenaline and epinephrine. Those are those are the chemicals that are secreted when we're excited and when we're anxious. Yeah. So you can just tell yourself that it's something different. So anxiety is obviously incredibly limiting at times can feel something like a life sentence. but what I really, really love about your work is that it kind of offers this more positive alternative to this perspective, you know, seeing anxiety, not so much as a super style, you know, per se,
太尴尬了。我唯一做的一件事，也是和你的经历非常相似的一点，就是我会告诉自己，我对这种感觉感到兴奋，因为我认为焦虑和兴奋的感觉非常非常相似。所以我就想，这是有史以来最令人兴奋的感觉。这其实是相同的化学物质，也就是肾上腺素。你知道的，肾上腺素和去甲肾上腺素。这些就是当我们感到兴奋和焦虑时分泌的化学物质。是的。所以你可以告诉自己这其实是别的东西。因此，焦虑有时显然具有极大的局限性，甚至让人感觉像是被判了无期徒刑。但我真正非常非常喜欢你的作品的是，它为这种观点提供了一种更积极的替代方案，你知道的，把焦虑看作并不是什么超能力，本身并不是这样，
but kind of you say this as your own personal confidence to kind of learn your limits. So can you expand on that a little bit? What is anxiety useful for? How can we listen to anxiety as a way to kind of teach us more, not just about our environment, but also about ourselves. Yeah, it's a good question. I think for people in their 20s especially, I want to go back to the conversation about loneliness.
而是你认为它是你个人的信心所在，可以借此去了解自己的极限。所以你能稍微展开谈谈吗？焦虑有什么用处？我们该如何倾听焦虑，把它当作一种途径，不仅能让我们更好地了解我们的环境，还能更好地了解我们自己？是的，这是个好问题。我认为特别是对二十几岁的人来说，我想回到关于孤独的话题。
And the people I know, the patients I know, who have had anxiety, have the ability, I would call it a superpower, to understand and to probe and to respond to the emotions of other people much better than people who aren't, I would say, blessed with anxiety, especially social anxiety. You know, people who are excessively shy, excessively socially anxious, can pick up on
据我所知，我认识的那些曾经经历过焦虑的人，拥有这样一种能力——我称之为超能力——能够比那些没有“幸”拥有焦虑（尤其是社交焦虑）的人更好地理解、探究和回应其他人的情绪。你知道，那些极度害羞、极度社交焦虑的人，能够捕捉到
incredible cues like facial changes in the facial expression or changes in voice intonation or in rate of speech in people's body language. The specific words that they pick up on are much more nuanced. and that can enhance our connection with others. Now, they might have a smaller group of friends. They might not be life of the party and have 500 or 100 people or whatever it is. But those intimate connections, if we use our anxiety to understand the emotional experience of others, it can make us into a much better friend.
不可思议的线索，比如面部表情的变化、声音语调的变化、说话语速的变化，或者是人们的身体语言。他们所捕捉到的具体词汇要细腻得多，而这可以增强我们与他人的连接。当然，他们可能只有较小的朋友圈。他们可能不是派对上的灵魂人物，没有500或1000个朋友，诸如此类。但那些亲密的连接，如果我们利用焦虑去理解别人的情感体验，就能让我们成为好得多的朋友。
And more importantly, let me ask you a question. Are you closer with people who you divulge intimate emotional details of your life to? Yeah, absolutely. I think, yeah. I think, but also, on a selective level, I think when you do that excessively, sometimes it actually puts the relationship with it. That's a fair point.
更重要的是，我问你一个问题。你和那些向其倾诉生活中私密情感细节的人更亲近吗？是的，绝对是。我认为，是的。我认为，但在某种选择性的层面上，当你过度这样做时，有时实际上会给这段关系带来压力。这倒是个中肯的观点。
That's a fair point. But when we have one or two friends who we can really cry on their shoulder and open up to them and say, hey, I'm having a hard time. Like, I really need your love, your support, your hug right now. Like, when we can be vulnerable in those relationships,
这倒是个中肯的观点。但当我们有一两个朋友，我们可以真正在他们的肩膀上痛哭，向他们敞开心扉，说：“嘿，我最近过得很艰难。真的需要你现在的爱、支持和拥抱。”当我们在这些关系中能够展露脆弱时，
that's, it's so critical. It's such a critical human need to be able to express our vulnerabilities. And anxiety, I think, is one of the things that gets us there. When we're feeling anxious and we reach out and get the love and support we need, those can be the best relationships that we'll ever have. I agree. I 100% agree. It's interesting because we talk about friends,
那真的非常关键。能够表达我们的脆弱是人类一项至关重要的需求。而焦虑，我认为就是能让我们做到这一点的因素之一。当我们感到焦虑并主动寻求并获得所需的爱与支持时，这些就会成为我们一生中拥有过的最好的关系。我同意，我百分之百同意。这很有趣，因为我们谈论的是朋友，
but perhaps it, you know, divulge even more about myself on this episode. you've made me open up. You know, the relationship that I actually see that is benefited from that the most is the relationship with my dad, because my dad has, I think, has really, has long struggled with anxiety. And I think I didn't realize that as a kid. And now I've realized it more, you know,
但也许，你知道的，在这期节目中透露更多关于我自己的事情吧。你让我敞开心扉。你知道，我真正看到从中受益最多的关系，其实是我和我父亲的关系，因为我父亲，我认为，长期以来一直在与焦虑作斗争。我想我小时候并没有意识到这一点。而现在我对此有了更多认识，你知道的，
when I was a teenager now into my 20s, where I'm like, oh, this is a shared experience. And I can tell when my dad is, more ready to open up to me in a way that I think a lot of Australian men really aren't because of the cultural, cultural milieu here. Like, you know, it's the sunburnt country you're meant to just go out and make a fair go for yourself and work really hard for your family. And it's, you know, got that whole like convict mentality.
当我成为青少年，现在进入二十多岁的时候，我会想，哦，这是一种共同的经历。我能看出我父亲什么时候更愿意对我敞开心扉，而我认为由于这里的文化环境，很多澳大利亚男人往往不愿这样做。你知道的，这里是那片被烈日炙烤的土地，人们认为你本就该走出去，为自己闯出一片天，为了家庭拼命工作。而且它，你知道的，带有那种整个囚犯流放地的精神底色。
That's how we were colonised, obviously. A history lesson for everyone. But I think the thing, like the times that I've understood him the best is when we've been able to bond over that that experience and also he's come you know he's been able to open up to me and been like this is you know I'm having this this anxious feeling and let's connect on that and get through it together so I do think it's definitely helped my relationship with my dad and it's probably not a relationship he had with his father at all and the same I could probably say about my mom and now my sisters as well so I actually think that's really fascinating that
显然，这就是我们被殖民的方式。给大家上堂历史课。但我认为最重要的事情是，我最理解他的那些时刻，正是我们能够通过那种经历建立羁绊的时候，而且他也来了，你知道的，他能够向我敞开心扉并说：“这就是，你知道的，我正经历着这种焦虑的感觉，让我们在这方面产生共鸣并一起度过难关。”所以，我确实认为这绝对有助于我和父亲的关系，这可能也是他和他父亲之间完全没有过的一种关系，我大概也可以对我的母亲和现在的姐姐们这么说。所以其实我真的觉得这一点非常迷人，
point. You're telling me that the fact that you experienced anxiety, you were able to recognize it in your father, get him to open up about it, despite cultural factors to the contrary, and that has enhanced your bond and your relationship. I'm giving myself too much credit. I think that he was doing his own work. Yeah, I think that there was like a moment. I also think it was necessity. It was like there was, it was by necessity whereby, you know, he's a parent. I'm not a parent, but I'm sure that when he was seeing me experience that pattern of symptoms, he was like, recognized himself in that. And I don't know, probably really wanted to comfort me and really share. Like, I've, I've been through the same thing. Maybe he didn't have a word for it. He came with me to my
那就是你告诉我，因为你经历过焦虑，所以你能够在你父亲身上识别出它，让他敞开心扉谈论它，尽管有相反的文化因素，而这增强了你们之间的纽带和关系。我是在给自己贴金了。我觉得他自己也在做努力。是的，我认为那是一个契机。我也认为这是出于必然。这就好像是，这是出于一种必然，你知道的，他是个父母。我不是父母，但我敢肯定，当他看到我经历那种症状模式时，他在其中认出了自己，而且我不知道，大概真的很想安慰我并真正分享：“我，我也经历过同样的事情。”也许他没有一个确切的词来形容它。他和我一起去参加了我的
sessions. You know, it's like that whole process. But that's exactly what thriving with anxiety is about. You, you and him have used anxiety to connect with each other. And that's what it's here for. I mean, it's not, have you, you know, if you only medicated it away without also engaging therapy and also engaging with your father about it. It would have been a tremendous opportunity missed, and I think many times that's what happens. And people are just left more alone, more anxious, more upset about the fact that they're anxious. And I'm seeing a lot of pain and a lot of isolation and a lot of just loneliness in our world because of we don't realize that anxiety is so normal and something that we can use for positive.
咨询。你知道的，就像整个那样的过程。但这就是与焦虑共存的真谛所在。你和他利用焦虑来彼此连接。而这正是它存在的意义。我的意思是，难道不是吗？如果你只是用药物把它压制下去，却不同时配合心理治疗，也不和你的父亲谈论它，那将是一个错失的巨大机会，而且我认为很多时候情况正是如此。人们只会变得更加孤立、更加焦虑、对自己的焦虑感到更加沮丧。而由于我们没有意识到焦虑是如此正常，并且是我们能够积极利用的东西，我在我们的世界里看到了很多痛苦、很多孤立以及很多孤独。
if we use the right techniques. So that kind of leads me to my last question. You have a book coming out tomorrow by the time people are listening to this, you will be able to get your hands on it. I have my hands on this book, but if not I would be buying an extra copy. I think it's going to be a Christmas present for a few of my close family and friends. Maybe my dad. But you talk about these nine tools to make anxiety work for you.
如果你使用正确的技术的话。所以这有点引出了我的最后一个问题。你明天将要出版一本书，等人们听到这里时，你们就能买到它了。我已经拿到这本书了，如果没有的话，我会多买一本。我想这会成为我送给几个亲近的家人和朋友的圣诞礼物。也许还有我爸爸。但你谈到了这九个让焦虑为你所用的工具。
Not to give everyone a sneak peek, but can you maybe discuss, maybe some of the most relevant ones you think would apply to people specifically in their 20s for who anxiety is definitely an everyday reality. The most relevant piece of information in the book is that our cultural tendency to try to squelch and get rid of our anxiety is not helpful. It is, A, not going to happen. You will never get rid of all your anxiety.
不是要给大家提前剧透，但你能不能讨论一下，或许其中最相关的、你认为特别适用于二十几岁人群的那些工具，对他们来说焦虑绝对是每天都要面对的现实。书中最重要的信息是，我们试图压制并摆脱焦虑的文化倾向是没有帮助的。第一，这是不可能发生的。你永远无法彻底摆脱所有的焦虑。
B, the more you try to get rid of your anxiety, B, the more you try to get rid of your anxiety, The anxiety, the worse it comes back. You know, anybody who's done cognitive behavior therapy knows this one. That if you don't accept it and if you don't, you know, let yourself feel it, then it's just going to make it worse. But see, most importantly, anxiety can teach you a lot about your own thoughts, about your own feelings. It can allow you to have more resilience that when you feel uncomfortable, it's not that anything else is, it's not that everything is going wrong. It's not that there's something that catastrophize about.
第二，你越是试图摆脱焦虑，焦虑就会越强烈地卷土重来。你知道，任何做过认知行为疗法的人都知道这一点。如果你不接受它，如果你不让自己去感受它，那么事情只会变得更糟。但第三，也是最重要的一点，焦虑可以教给你很多关于你自己的想法、你自己的感受。它可以让你拥有更强的韧性，当你感到不舒服时，并不意味着其他任何事情都……并不是一切都在出错。并不是有什么需要被灾难化看待的事情。
about that's called having a human tapestry, a rich tapestry of human emotion. And like we spoke about with you and your dad, you can parlay that into our relationships, perhaps most important for your generation. A lot of people are very ambitious today. If you're going to pursue your dreams, you are going to hit stress, you are going to hit struggles, you are going to feel anxious. And the more we can learn to experience and allow ourselves to experience anxiety, the better positioned we are to truly accomplish our unique goals and dreams in this world. So that's kind of a summary of the book in, I don't know, was that 10 sentences or something? I think so.
这就是所谓拥有丰富多彩的人生，拥有丰富的人类情感画卷。就像我们之前谈到你和你父亲一样，你可以把这一点转化为我们人际关系中的力量，这或许对你们这一代人最为重要。现在很多人都很有雄心壮志。如果你要追求自己的梦想，你就会遭遇压力，你就会遇到挣扎，你就会感到焦虑。我们越是能够学会去体验并允许自己体验焦虑，我们就越能处于更有利的地位，去真正实现我们在这个世界上的独特目标和梦想。所以这算是对这本书的一个总结吧，我不知道，那是10句话左右吗？我想是的。
Pep Talk, I didn't know I needed. Feels like that was, that was hand-selected for me. I want to say, thank you so much for coming on. One final question. What do you think is the current biggest misconception about anxiety in this generation? I believe we have construed anxiety as a disease, as a malady. And yes, of course, it can get disordered in certain cases and excessive to the point that it becomes debilitating.
这是一剂我此前不知道自己需要的强心针。感觉就像是，那是专门为我挑选的。我想说，非常感谢你能来。最后一个问题。你认为当前这一代人对焦虑最大的误解是什么？我相信我们把焦虑曲解成了一种疾病，一种病症。是的，当然，在某些情况下它可能会失调，并过度到令人衰弱的程度。
But one of the primary reasons why we're doing that is because we don't embrace it. We don't understand that this is part and parcel of our humanity. We are limited, finite creatures in a very complex world. And if we're going to feel overwhelmed and stressed and anxious at times, well, guess what? That means you're human. We don't have that perspective. And when we start to accept and understand this is part of life, we can use it.
但我们之所以这样做的一个主要原因，是我们没有接纳它。我们不明白这是我们人性的一部分。在一个非常复杂的世界里，我们是有局限的、有限的生物。如果我们有时会感到不堪重负、压力重重和焦虑不安，好吧，你猜怎么着？这意味着你是个人。我们没有这种视角。而当我们开始接受并理解这是生活的一部分时，我们就可以利用它。
I think we can use it for good. I really do think we can use it for good. I'm hoping that everyone is listening loud and clear to that. I think I agree with that. I want to say thank you so much for coming on. And I'm super excited about your book. I want to really plug it to the listeners here. If you have an interest, it looks amazing.
我想我们可以为了好的目的利用它。我真的认为我们可以为了好的目的利用它。我希望每个人都把这话听得清清楚楚。我想我是同意这一点的。我想说非常感谢你能来。我超级期待你的书。我想在这里向听众们强烈推荐它。如果你有兴趣的话，它看起来棒极了。
I think that if you love this podcast, it's evidence-based. You're going to love this book as well. So thank you so much, Dr. Reserman, for coming on the show and for joining us for this conversation. Thanks for having me. What an honor and a pleasure to meet you. Absolutely. Anytime. Thank you so much for listening to today's episode.
我想如果你喜欢这个播客，它是基于证据的，你也会喜欢这本书的。所以非常感谢雷瑟曼博士来到节目中，并加入我们进行这次对话。谢谢邀请我。能见到你真是我的荣幸和快乐。绝对的。随时欢迎。非常感谢收听今天的节目。
If you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify. wherever you are listening right now. If you have an episode suggestion, you can follow me at That Psychology Podcast, or if you have something to say about this episode, we'd love to hear it. So get in touch. And we will be back next week for another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。如果你有节目建议，你可以关注我：That Psychology Podcast，或者如果你对本期节目有什么想说的，我们很乐意倾听。所以请与我们联系。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇异的现代世界中建立韧性的方法。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWA%”。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。
It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences,
那是狂野的一年。那是狂野的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。请在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，你们好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·吉姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，
having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
进行一些在任何地方都实在不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，请在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。在2023年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是《受困于爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困于爱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是真人制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。